okay so The Avengers infinity war the
art of the movie book is now out and
these books usually include some things
that we really didn't know about the
movie including some scenes that never
made it into the movie some designs for
characters that they had in mind that
never made it into the movie as well and
sometimes they do a little bit of
foreshadowing and give us a little bit
of a preview as to what to expect from
sequels and I actually think that we
have quite a bit of that in this book
I'll be doing a few breakdowns and
reviews of the book within the next
upcoming week so stay tuned for that
also I'm still doing my giveaway giving
away copies of infinity war Deadpool 2
and ant-man and the wasp as well as some
special edition posters all you have to
do to enter for your chance to win is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero so
there are a few pictures in this book of
a scene that was not an Avengers
infinity war but one in particular could
give us a preview and could be
foreshadowing exactly what we could
possibly see in Avengers 4
these pictures show a very different
ending than what we actually saw and
these photos we see all of the Avengers
holding down Thanos as Thor delivers his
final blow
also this scene is not secluded from the
battle between the outriders and the
wakandans as you can see it's right in
the middle of the battle it's easy to
miss but if you look closely you can see
war machine fighting the outriders with
the wakandans war machine is holding
back the outriders while groot Black
Widow Black Panther Captain America and
the Hulk not Bruce Banner but the Hulk
are holding Thanos down for Thor to come
in and strike him in the chest with
Stormbreaker as you can see vanos has
all of the stones and is trying to snap
his fingers but Captain America is
holding the gauntlet this scene is
actually really similar to the scene on
Titan on Titan we had the guardians of
the galaxy
spider-man Doctor Strange and Iron Man
all holding down Thanos trying to get
the gauntlet off so if they put that
scene in why didn't they put this scene
in well perhaps it wasn't ever really
meant for infinity war and the Infinity
Gauntlet saga in the comics The Avengers
and the rest of the heroes know exactly
how strong vanos is with all of the
Infinity stones they launched a massive
attack on him all of them at the same
time together and there have been a
number of supposed plot leaks that have
come out all differing from each other a
little bit but one thing they all have
in common is that the Avengers and the
rest of the heroes launch a massive
attack against Thanos together and from
very early on since the first Avengers
movie and in Avengers age of Ultron the
Avengers have talked about unity and
doing everything together in Infinity
Ward the Avengers fought separately and
lost somewhere on Titan somewhere in
Wakanda and in Wakanda the avengers
didn't exactly face Thanos together it
was sort of one on one each avenger
going after the next and some joined the
battle pretty late and obviously that
didn't work but here's the thing time
travel is going to be a huge part in
Avengers for the Avengers we'll go back
in time to undo some events specifically
Civil War altering the events of Civil
War 2 where it actually has a happy
ending we'll make it to where all of the
Avengers can be together when Thanos
arrives so you'll have all of the
Avengers together and they'll also know
what they did wrong in infinity war so I
expect this scene in these photos to
play out in Avengers 4 with the
exception of all of the other heroes are
going to be there as well the Hulk is
out in this photo which we know will
happen in Avengers 4 and although Thor
still aims for the chest Captain America
is holding the gauntlet to keep Thanos
from snapping once Thor hits him with
Stormbreaker Thanos will most likely be
weak enough for the Avengers to hold him
down and Captain America to take the
gauntlet off him this would be modeled
loosely after the Infinity Gauntlet saga
where the Avengers take the gauntlet
from Thanos to defeat him which is
really the only way that he can be
defeated to take the Infinity Gauntlet
from him again they could have easily
put this scene in the movie this scene
on Titan was pretty much exactly like it
but it was most likely too similar to
the final battle in Avengers 4 so they
decided to leave it out but what do you
all think of this do you think that this
is a possible preview and foreshadowing
of what we could see happen in Avengers
4 or do you think that it'll end in some
other way let me know what you think in
the comments below and don't forget to
subscribe comment and like the video so
you can enter the giveaway and stay up
to date on everything related to
Avengers 4 as always thank you all so
much for watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]